- [Instructor] Where we left
off in the last few videos
we saw the Empire of the Mongols
fragment into the various Khanates.
In the east you have the Yuan Dynasty
established by Kublai Khan.
And then in the west you
have the Golden Horde,
the Chagatai Khanate
and then the Ilkhanate
in much of the Middle East and Persia.
Now as we go a little bit
further into the 14th century,
and in particular the
1330s, you might remember
when we studied Europe, that
the bubonic plague hits,
and it doesn't just hit
Europe, it hits Asia.
And one of the causes often
given for the rapid spread
is that you had relative
stability formed by these Khanates
so that trade was able to
happen, but with that trade
you also have the spread of disease.
And so the bubonic
plague, or the Black Death
of the 1330s, in particular does damage
to the Ilkhanate in Persia
and the Middle East.
Not only the Emperor but his sons
all die from the bubonic plague.
And so you see here on
this timeline the Ilkhanate
goes into a rapid decline
because of the Black Death.
And at the same time,
in the southwest corner
of the Chagatai Khanate, a
future conqueror is born.
Timur, which means iron,
he's often known as Timurlane
because when he was young he was injured
in both the hand and leg
by arrows which impaired
his movement and which
is why the Europeans
called him Timur the Lame,
which became Timurlane.
But despite his physical
impairments he's able to conquer
much of the Chagatai Khanate eventually
and the Ilkhanate and
establish a dynasty of his own.
The Empire gets established
in 1370 when he gets
effective power over much of
the western Chagatai Khanate.
He comes from a Turko-Mongol tradition.
Now you'll hear these
terms Turko-Mongol a lot,
because even though the Mongols conquered
this large swath of territory, they did so
with the significant help of people
speaking Turkic languages
from central Asia,
Turkish being the most well
known of the Turkic languages.
And so many of the conquerors,
especially the Muslim conquerors
of central Asia and Persia of this period
are of a Turko-Mongol ethnicity.
Even though there's no
evidence of him being
a direct descendant of
Genghis Khan, or Genghis Khan,
he views himself as the successor,
he wants to recreate
the great Mongol Empire.
By the time of Timur's
death, the Timurid Empire
encompasses much of Persia, central Asia,
the Caucasus and the Middle East.
His legacy is a bloody one,
as he expanded territory
and took over cities it was not uncommon
for his soldiers to kill tens,
if not hundreds of thousands
of civilians who revolted
against Timur's rule.
His forces famously attacked
the Delhi Sultanate,
not hoping to conquer India,
but to take its spoils.
In 1398 he was able to
successfully defeat the Sultan
who had battle elephants and
he was able to defeat them
by sending camels that had flames
on their backs to scare the elephants.
And famously, when his forces took Delhi,
they killed 100,000 to 200,000 people
and took the spoils of the city.
There are some estimates
that Timur's forces killed
as many as 17 million people
as the Empire expanded.
To put this into
perspective, this is roughly
five percent of the world's
population at that time.
Now once Timur dies in
1405, you can see from
this timeline that the
Empire does not last long,
as we get to the second half of
the 15th century, it is in decline.
Now some of his descendants
end up ruling over
fragmented portions of this Empire,
and as we get into the 16th century
we'll see one descendant in particular,
his grandson's great grandson takes on
the Delhi Sultanate and
established the Mughal,
which is Persian for
Mongol, establishes the
Mughal Empire in northern India.